MICHEL DEGRAFF: So one good
thing about this course
is that the students
who take it,
they seem to already be
aware that there's something
that they need to, I would say,
unlearn about Creole languages.
So because you can see
that in the answers
to the first
questionnaire I give,
because I start the
course by asking them
some basic questions
to know where
they are in terms of what they
know about Creole languages.
And I think most of
them, the answers
reflect what they
would have learned
in the typical linguistic
textbooks, which
I've been myself critiquing.
So the idea that Creole
languages are mixed languages,
and that makes them
special languages,
exceptional
languages, or the idea
that Creole languages are
somehow oversimplified,
they are reduced languages
that are lesser than others.
So that came up in
some of their answers.
But at the same time, many of
them, from the very beginning,
they would share
very, I would say,
fine answers in terms
of understanding
that Creole languages emerged
in the context of very
drastic power imbalance.
And as such,
attitudes towards them
reflect this power imbalance.
And so they came
ready to critique
what they had learned in the
linguistic textbooks, which
to me was very heartening
to start the course with.
So one way that we start by
unpacking these misconceptions
is by comparing attitudes
towards languages
with attitudes towards
race and ethnicity.
And what they get
to see very quickly
is that, in fact,
there is perhaps
as much misconceptions
about language
as there is about race.
So they get to see very
early in the course
that language can be
used as a proxy for race.
Though now it's impolite to
say certain things about, say,
black people or Asian
people, yet it's
still polite to say pretty
negative things about language.
And then at that
point what we do,
we introduce some basic
linguistic analysis
tools for them to be
able to see that in terms
of linguistic
structure, there is
nothing at all that's inferior
about Creole languages.
In fact, what we do from the
very beginning is to show that,
structurally,
there are patterns,
both in the syntax or
morphology of Creole languages,
that are quite
similar to patterns
in the syntax and history
of English or French,
of Mandarin Chinese.
And so they quickly get
a sense that empirically
and theoretically, one cannot
argue that Creole languages are
any way lesser than
non-Creole languages,
the same way that there are no
biological measures that would
deem black people to be
inferior to white people.
So they get very
quick to understand
the power of this myth
that, often, they themselves
have brought along
in terms of how
they view different languages--
in some cases Creole languages,
and in other cases just
even dialects of English,
say, Southern English
or black English.
They are attitudes that
are very demeaning to us
as varieties that have no basis
in science, that are rooted
in hierarchies of power.
And they get to see
that very quickly.